[音楽]
私は
音楽家2回がが大好きな両親のもとに生まれました
みんな
赤貝
奥手
[音楽]
朝にいい
いうと
私も歌が大好きなんです
今日は私が中2の時に起きたある出来事とちょっとユニークな私の家族を通して気づい
た事をみなさんにシェアしたいと思います
私が生まれた時両親は2000年生まれだから200人抱っこ計画をしようと考えまし
た
そのときの写真がこれです
素敵でしょ
私が生まれる前両親はぜったいに幸せな家庭を築くと決めていたそうです
幸せ家族になるためにはどうすればいいか
父と母は本を読んだり話を聞いたり
ドリームマップを作ってみたりもしました
そんな早川家は両親私弟2人と妹のら9人
わくわく楽しい幸せ家族です
私たちの家族には早川家キャンぽーというのがあります
代以降は2004年頃に両親が作りました
家のトイレに貼ってあって
私たち子どもは暗唱できてしまうほどでした
私たち家族はいつも笑っている私たち家族はお互いを尊重し合っている
私たち家族はチームだ
などです
そんな家に生まれた私は200人だっこーのおかげか
物怖じせず人の目を全く気にしない明るくて元気な響ちゃんだったそうです
誰にでも通りすがりの人にも10m くらい離れた人にもおはようございます
[音楽]
挨拶をして回ったり突然歌って踊り出したり
そんな響ちゃんに幼稚園の頃ある事件が起きました
ん
年少さんの時に先生にほめられている子がいたんです
困ってるコスッと+けど女の子先生が取っても褒めていたんです
私も褒められたい
こうすれば褒めてもらえるんだって思った私はたくさん手伝ってほめられてうれしくて
そこから優等生響ちゃんができあがっていきました
みんなの意見を聞いてまとめたり先生に話しかけて悩みを聞いたり
授業中には浜4人みたいに武山
耳につくくらいピンと手を挙げて
6芸会の当日には先生にまた真の挨拶よろしくっていきなり言われて
ほぼアドリブで話したこともありました
そうすると決まって友だちのや先生などに響ちゃんすごいねありがとうって褒めて
もらえました
私はそれが嬉しかったのと同時に
本当はこんな人間じゃないのになーって
心のどこかで思っていました
中学校に入ってもそれは続きました
当然のように旧長に推薦されて
違和感を覚えていたのに私は断りきれず副級長になりましたって
その違和感はどんどんふくらんで
イライラして
何にイライラしているのか理由なんて何も思いつかなくて
頭が体が心が気持ち悪くなっていって
ドロドロした溝のもみたいに私の内側にくっついてるみたい
それでも私は
その違和感に気づかないふりをしていいコちゃんを続けました
クラスメイトに声をかけてたくさん意見をあげて
入った吹奏楽部では来年の木簡リーダーは響ちゃんじゃないって噂になったりもしまし
た
でも
限界だったのかついに中2の夏
起き上がれなくなってしまいました
体調を崩して
病院ではホルモン過多と診断されました
ホルモン過多は女性ホルモンが過剰分泌されて体調不良を引き起こし頂上です
私の場合体がパンパンにむくんだり立っていられないほどのめまいがしたり
そして
学校に行けなくなりました
体調が悪い日だけじゃなくて体調が良い日も学校には行きませんでした
なぜ行かないのか自分でも分からずただモヤモヤしていました
それを助けてくれたのは母でした
そのモヤモヤを何でもいいからノートに書いてみたら
布団の中に潜っていた私はその言葉に点を待ち
神の前に座りました
その時は何を書いているのかよく分からないまま頭に浮かんだまま紙にペンを走らせ
ました
落ち着いて書いているときもあればパニック状態です
アーとかウーウーとか書いてる時もありました
分からない分からないって書いてる時もありました
後からそのノートを読むと自分が客観的に見えてきます
ある日読んで気づいたのは怒りでした
ん
私は部活の顧問の先生に怒っていました
その先生は音楽が大好きです
とても熱心に教えてくださる方で
私はとても尊敬しているんですが
怒る時に一生懸命になりすぎて
人格を否定したような言い方をしていたんです
その先生に私は怒っていました
でも長いこと優子ちゃんをやってきた私は自分の中にそんな闇の感情があるのが信じ
られませんでした
またモヤモヤしてきました
そして布団に潜ります
そこへ母が紙とペンを持ってきてくれました
また私は何も考えず紙にペンを走らせます
次の日落ち着いてから読むと即にはやっぱり先生の怒りが書いてありました
自分の気持ちが目で見てわかるんです
これはもう認めざるを得ません
私は硬化後にアポをとって学校に行きました
そしてノートを見せながら先生と二人で話をしました
先生は泣きながら私の話を聞いてくれて
さあたーって思いました
でも
それからも先生は変わりませんでした
そして気付いたんです
このモヤモヤは私が作り出しているんだッ
先生に怒らされているのではなく私がこの人に怒ってるんだと
もう一度ノートみました
ちゃんと見ると先生自身がにくいんじゃなくて先生の見方とか考え方が許せないんです
ノートに書いて見えるようにしたことで客観的に自分の怒りを見ることができたんです
今でもこのノートを見ると
怒りと憎しみが湧いてきます
でもそれは前ほど嫌なものじゃありません
受け入れたことで
自分にはこんな感情もあるんだどーん
自分を否定することはなくなりました
一つの事実を
私は一つの塊で捉えていました
こんな感じに
でもその一つの事実は
一つの塊ではなくたくさんの塊が重なり合ってできている出来事の一部なんだと気づき
ました
そして
その塊にはそれぞれから作り出される感情があります
同じ出来事でも選ぶ塊によって感情が変わってきます
だからどんな風にも感じることができるんです
私は
この出来事を
憎しみでつらい出来事から
大切なことに気付くことができた出来事と捉え直すことで
受け入れられない怒りは受け入れられる怒りに変わったんです
してい
くさんの
出来事が
この世界にはあふれています
つらい出来事以外にも
私たちの周りにはたくさんの感情であふれています
今自分はどう痛いのかどんな自分が好きなのか
それによってたくさんある出来事の中から今自分に必要なものを選ぶんです
今この瞬間からも選べるんです
猪狩
悲しみ
嬉しさ楽したほかにもたくさんの感情に囲まれながら生きています
どの漢字を選ぶかは
自分で決められるんです
パニックにはついた時気持ちがぐしゃぐしゃになったとき
私は
今その現場を知ることで客観的に自分を見ることができ
どうしたいかがわかってきました
その現状を知るために何度もいいからノートに書くという作業が私にはしっくりきまし
た
パニックになってもぐしゃぐしゃになってもいいんです
むしろなった方が大きくなれるかもしれません
私は
自分が好きになりました
私は今どう痛いのかどんな自分が好きなのか
それによってたくさんある出来事の中から
自分が好きなものを選び
考え
行動できる大人になっていきたいとおもいます
自分の日のことが分かり始めた私は
早川家の憲法に疑問が出てきました
いつも笑顔じゃなくてもよくないつもプラスの言葉を使ってなくてもよくな
怒りたい気分の時もあるもん
それを両親に言うと
その言葉を待っていた
私たちはこう思って憲法を作ったけど2人だけで作ったんだ
さあ家族会議しよう
まず
私たち家族はいつも笑っているという部分が
自分で自分の機嫌をとっているになりました
私の中で一番大きかったのはあ
私のいつも笑っている必要ないと思うという意見と
父の思いが重なった瞬間です
前まではどんな状況であれいつも笑っていられる精神的ゆとりを作るために
何でも良いほうに捉えて
自分の闇を見ないようにというか負の感情を作らないようにしていたんですが
憲法改正してからは
自分の負の感情も出せるようになってきました
そして
憲法改定版には私たち家族は人生を思いっきり楽しんでいる
やりたいことがやれる環境であるがあります
私も成長し今やりたいことがたくさん出てきました
家族はそれは受け入れて
応援し困ったときにはいつでもサポートしてくれます
もちろん父も母も弟も妹も今やりたいことをやっています
私もそれを応援しサポートしていきます
最初に両親が作ったん
私たち家族はチームだは今も生きています
私たち家族が一番大切にしていることがからです
チームとはお互いが対等に協力し合って尊重し合って役割を果たしている集団
仲間だと私は思っています
子どもたちがこうやって意見を言えるようになり
会議ができるようになったということは早川家がチームっぽくなってきたということだ
と思います
これからも
私たち家族は
家族の成長に合わせて
誰かがいきゃーん
言いたいとき誰かが新しいことに気づいた時にまた家族会議が開かれ憲法は改正されて
いくんだと思います
そしてその変化こそが
私たちの求める幸せ家族の形なんじゃないかなぁと私は思い始めています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]